Only you have the power to change you.
Let's do this thing.
♪ To the point of no return ♪
♪♪
Sheila:
Today you will eat clean healthy
foods.
Sheila:
After school drop-off you will
go directly to ballet class.
(Tires skidding)
Sheila:
I will have a nice day.
Danny:
Babe, the coffee.
(Tapping noise)
Sheila:
I will eat clean healthy food.
Three famous cheeseburgers,
three large fires and a
chocolate shake.
Thanks.
Sheila:
After school drop-off...
Mama
Oh...!
Sheila:
... I will go to ballet class...
Man:
It's closed.
Sheila:
...I will have a nice day.
Professor Rubin is getting
fired.
Danny:
We're gonna need money.
I love you, whatever
happens.
You think something bad will
happen?
No!
Sheila:
You're trusting this ding-dong
with your life.
Sheila inner voices:
I will have a nice day.
Woman: You had so much going for you.
Sheila inner voices:
Danny: Sheila!
Sheila: Three.
Danny:
Did you hear that Sheila?
Sheila:
You're as shallow as a kiddie
pool. Two.
Danny: Earth to Sheila, hello
Sheila: One.
Stop it!
What's up, lady?
Sorry.
♪♪
Bunny:
You ready to do this thing?
Sheila:
Now you've done it, she see what
a mess you are
โ ชโ ช
Sheila:
Actually I feel better then I
have been in a long time.
โ ชโ ช
Danny:
Where are you going?
Sheila:
Out!
I've been doing aerobics
classes.
You should try it.
Sheila:
You might like it.
And after just one class you
can feel it happening.
Shelia:
You becoming you again.
Danny:
How long can we afford to live
off of our savings?
We all gotta to do our part.
Sheila:
And by we, he means you.
You every think of hiring
another teacher?
If you screw this up, you're
done here.
Sheila:
Skanky bottled blonde.
Shelia:
To the right.
Oh, sorry, I meant your left.
♪ I wanna be ♪
I can't keep up.
Greta:
Blend in.
I feel like that constantly.
Sheila:
I could come to your house.
Shelia:
I could teach you aerobics
there.
Bunny:
There's a small chance it might
not be a lame business idea.
♪  Take me to the point of no
return ♪
Sheila:
Punch, punch, punch, punch!
♪♪
You don't know what I'm capable
of.
♪♪
Shelia:
You've built something,
something solid
Sheila:
that's all yours.
What the hell is all this?
Sheila:
No one is taking it away.
♪ Hey hey hey taking me ♪
Don't underestimate me.
♪  To the point of no return. ♪
Sheila:
Go get em, tiger.
♪ Hey hey hey yeah oh oh oh ♪